let's let's jump from biden's broken
brain to where we get into
like the freaky and uh this story like
rightly freaked me out i'm gonna start
by saying something very very simple
dr fauci is not your doctor and he
doesn't know what's right for you
because you could have some weird growth
on your butt i don't know your doctor's
got to tell you what that what that is
not fouchy
and joe rogan as well these people are
allowed to have their opinions of course
but you got to talk to your own doctors
i say to 51 million times
because we have the story here columbus
judge is adding a new term to
defendant's probation get your coveted
shot
this is literally a judge sentencing
people
to vaccination let me give you an
example they say a man named cameron
stringer
entered a guilty plea for one charge of
improperly handling firearms in a motor
vehicle
for which he was sentenced to two years
of probation they call it community
control in ohio i just want to point out
is that it second amendment lawsuit
right there right yes
if somebody gets sentenced to to
probation because they were handling
firearms
i'm mishandling them then i think there
may be an advocacy group which could sue
get this taken up the supreme court file
an appeal and maybe get it overturned
on the grounds of like you're allowed to
handle firearms whatever
now in this instance i guess what
happened was the gun wasn't his
so ohio was like not yours give it back
to the owner
two years probation and stringer must
submit to random drugs to a random drug
screening
avoid further legal trouble return a
firearm in question to its rightful
owner
and obtain a covet 19 vaccine within 30
days and provide proof
to the to the probation department
i don't get it yeah why is a judge
telling people to get a medical
treatment
this is the problem when you have 50
million celebrities all being like
you should go get a specific could you
let me slow down imagine if you had
every celebrity
being like you should all be taking uh
percocets
like no no no no no no like yes i
understand why
we prescribe these painkillers to people
who really need them
but celebrities shouldn't be going on
it's actually against the law i'm pretty
sure
for them to do ads that that they have
to like label them
as ads when they advocate for anything
like a medical treatment or whatever
yet in this instance it is widely
acceptable and in fact
you can get banned for even questioning
it the doctor's got to be the one to
tell you man
slight question if the celebrities were
like you should roll around in the mud
but then if they were like you should
roll around the mud because it's good
for your immune system
is that then considered health advice
where the first one's not
the the issue is you're allowed to give
all the health advice in the world
except on this one issue
that's the weirdest thing now there's a
really really
there right i know right right the judge
is not a doctor what happens if this guy
goes to the doctor and the doctor is
like
uh you've got a lump on your butt i'm
recommending no for the vaccinations
gotta overrule the court
right right right but what if he's like
i don't care i don't care the doc he's
like
he should be saying you should go to a
doctor and uh
and request an evaluation to see if you
could get the vaccine and if you can we
would like you to get it
even that is weird right you know like
even saying like i'm not gonna order you
to get your vaccine in 30 days
but i recommend like what
judge what what jurisdiction
everything is about jurisdiction there
that's what i'm curious about where is
the jurisdiction
to include that what if the doctor was
like
um have you had your appendix removed
and the guy's like um no no your honor
why not
i don't know well within 30 days submit
proof that you've had it removed
so i understand one's a more serious
medical procedure than the other but i'm
super curious what is the precedent for
this
we just got done talking about the
tuskegee syphilis
experiments like under what
circumstances should a governing body be
able to tell you
you're going to get a medical procedure
you guys you guys are going to love the
next part of this
this is an article from dispatch.com
this is a usa today network
website gary daniels a lobbyist with the
aclu expressed concern about the
practice thursday
comparing it to ohio judges who have
ordered defendants convicted of crimes
not to procreate
i'm staying away from ohio i'm glad i
left what
love you ohio but come on yeah mr
crossland you have been convicted
of rocking the gange uh for this you can
never have kids no babies
you can't stop me your honor what the
hell much love bro
this dude this dude apparently so like i
actually have the story this guy
um apparently had 11 kids and his
humanist crime was
not paying child support are you joking
that was the crime
oh and so they were like you can't have
any more kids and he was like
bs and he sued and said you can't tell
me i can't have kids
yeah and the supreme court was like you
can't tell someone they can't have kids
that's what i'm wondering with this
other thing is like my worry is like
do they have jurisdiction is is there
some
weird wording in the loophole i'm pretty
sure they do
a lot of people since the vaccine thing
started have been saying like
you can't mandate medical treatments and
you have no right to my private records
and i'm fairly certain i could be wrong
with this that
there's an exception in the american
disabilities act
for public health requirements and that
does make sense i mean like
come on if there was a zombie apocalypse
you'd be right on board with whatever we
had to do to stop the zombie apocalypse
the issue now is actually i took that
back like it's politics man you'd be
surprised people i don't think
people know how to trust and and i know
this is like it might seem like a huge
jump but even if there was a zombie
apocalypse imagine the amount of people
who would be like
i i don't trust what anyone tells me i'm
going to deal with this my way
and i i kind of feel like that would be
a big issue like even if there were
a world event that could unite everybody
i don't think people know how to trust
enough right now especially not right
now i don't know if they ever did
you're probably right about that yeah um
maybe small communities but
this like countries that are this big
definitely not
but there is rule by fear so i'd be
willing to bet that if like a zombie
apocalypse happened in china
they would just gun everybody down and
say like look
you know collateral damage if we if we
shoot everybody we'll save the 10
on you know non-zombie people right or
you have to move to ohio that's that's
even worse
yeah in ohio there was this man who um
uh his house burnt down his cat died in
the house fire i forget his name i think
it was youngstown ohio but anyway he
um he had a pacemaker a smart pacemaker
and afterwards the um
the fire department noticed that the
fire looked like it was set in several
different locations of the house
so they went to the manufacturer of his
pacemaker
to get the data they used that in court
to show that he was very active when the
fires were set
so his pacemaker testified against him
in court
holy crap did you hear the story about
uh there's like a murder
and then the police subpoenaed amazon
for i'm not gonna say the robot's name
because we have one
uh subpoenaed like there's a recording
of this and everybody was like that's
not possible you have to tell it to
record and they were like oh no i
recorded everything
these these i heard more about that
apparently so is it domestic this is the
domestic abuse
yeah something like that and and it
turned on and then the guy was like did
you call the sheriff
and then it called the sheriff when it
heard that
and then the sheriff listened in i don't
believe it this is what i heard yeah i
was it's interesting
i can't get that dumb thing to play the
right song half the time
i'm trying to get it to play some
mountain john and it keeps putting on
some other weird modern hip hop gardens
all over the world
yeah seriously it's it's got like 20. i
want to hear goodbye yellow brick road
it's got like 2050 technology in what
data they're trying to gather but when
you're trying to get your song to play
it's it's like circa 1922 technology
but but remember when they were when
police departments were using
ring cameras that people have on their
front doors they were hacking in and
they had
like a deal with i think it was amazon
and these these
entire police departments could just tap
on it whenever they wanted to
so i totally believe that they used the
little friend over there to call the
sheriff
when somebody mentioned that it's all
for our safety i hope you guys know that
i feel very
right safety over security security over
freedom what does charles eisenstein
call it he said
we have been bowing at the altar of
safety
for so long and somebody else put it in
a way he said um
he said like what we need to be doing is
is demonstrating living at all costs
rather than staying alive at all costs
and
it really does seem like the way you
manage people is you make them believe
that death and destruction and bad
things are
right around the corner unless behavior
modulation and behavior
you know it's it's i mean you have to
modify your behavior let me let me let
me read you the story from
sciencemag.org
a judge said police can search the dna
of one million americans without their
consent
what's next there's also several stories
of states pushing back on
police subpoenaing ancestry data so
people get these kits from these you
know
these these 23andme and then the cops
are like
let's hit him up and get that data and
so now it's it's like a big legal battle
and uh this is an older story but uh
very much so
where was that this is science
sciencemac.org it just says uh i can
read a little bit
uh search warrant reported by the new
york times raises alarming possibility
of similar police searches
of giant direct consumer dna sites such
as ancestry and 23andme
that are now closed to everyone except
custom company customers willingly
submit saliva samples
they so they say a detective wanted to
find distant relatives of a serial
abuser hopefully that way in hopes of uh
in hopes their family trees could help
them
hone in on a suspect even the mo even
though most of the 1.3 million people
who have shared their dna with the site
haven't agreed to such
a search so this is a genealogy site
called the ged match
not the first time it won't be the last
time no data misappropriation
is literally written into the fine print
so it can be shared
in case of x y and z and x y and z can
be pulled out of any hat and i
just prints on your phone interesting
how many people have taken their
smartphone and given it all their
fingerprints for convenience
and now itunes or i'm sorry apple and
google are like
when you have you read the terms on this
thing i'd be willing to bet it says
you give us access to your fingerprint
image to use and exploit as we see fit
because how else would it actually work
they need permission to use your
fingerprint then they have it
and when they get subpoenaed for your
fingerprints congratulations you're
fingerprinted
yeah totally totally and you mentioned
ancestry.com they were just bought
not too long ago 75 of which bought by
blackstone
the other twenty-five percent is owned
by china
believe that check it out no way
ancestry.com last
august kind of what terrifies me that
apple now has
my fingerprints you know theoretically
is that they could then put my
fingerprint somewhere
blackstone bought your dna come on man
look at this
house yes blackstone.com
literally from their website blackstone
completes acquisition of ancestry
leading online
family history business for 4.7 billion
yo they bought your dna
dude and you know what the funny thing
is i'll tell you this
they don't got my dna they got my
parents dna yeah
they got both my parents dna so they got
they got some amalgamation of yours
though they don't know exactly which
ones made it through but
they might have enough they might know
that you are 97.3
likely to have a certain gene marker or
something like that thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time